in hindi they say that
it's a him means
snow
and allah means
a board of snow
so they look at
not only snow but also look in that god
also himalaya
is a sanskrit word
means ice
means house
so it is
he means isa snow so it's a kind of a
snow house
and himalay in general is seen
by nepali people and which which is
shared among different cultural groups
that himalaya are kind of a grainy store
so i i come from
pokhara area and so they have named
so
so snow is considered as
a grain
because of his because of its distant
role
uh in in producing grain because snow
eventually
becomes water goes to river it irrigates
and produces food i'm say all mountain
regions of the world they are always
seen in terms of altitudinal transects
means a change in altitude but himalayas
are the exception the sense that it has
a huge east to restart
with
it's about 2 500 kilometer
and
along the arc you can find all kinds of
civilizations religions
almost all all the all the four
principal religions of the say globe
means islam
buddhism hinduism christianity you can
find that that whole art of course
people move uh
across the himalayas um along the
himalayan range
and they have been doing so not only now
since past
so if you look into for example the uh
settlement of people
in nepal
so from about say
11th 12th century
the movement is from west to east
uh major flow of people they were
indigenous people in different locations
but the major flow of people took place
uh west to east
uh and that shows that it's not only uh
not south and in this process they have
taken
new knowledge from one area to another
new plants by
biological things seeds
and so it has spread from
uh east to east
and then
you can see the there's a there's
several you could say environmental
gradients
one of them for example if you ever say
if you consider it's trending well in
some part make hale then you have a
rainfall
something about 10 000 centimeter and
then you can find some of the biggest
rain shadow areas in tibet
of the world and then it enables you
to look at the whole
and that perhaps would give you many
many new ideas which
generally people
don't get upon you to to look at i look
at this uh himalayan ale himalayan
initiative as a as a major say
step in the direction of
developing knowledge in the sense that
himalayas provide several ecological
questions biological anthropogenic
questions and this is a good idea i'm
saying to really think about
considering himalayas a system for doing
this kind of research
in order to better manage resources
improve the condition
we also need
science
science and traditional knowledge
they have to combine together in order
to improve the situation
so um with this institution uh i think
we can do some scientific
research which has a good expertise here
uh with local researchers
and then find out the uh the solution
we are cautiously we are trying to
really uh make our own way and raise
questions which are big which encompass
the whole arc but uh but uh
it should be feasible and it should be
realistic approach so it has is this
taking time but i'm glad that uh
uh we are we have we have reached the
point where from where we can think that
uh we will have a proposal which has
some meaning
to funding agencies
uh i know i think it's a good initiative
they were i think they were both
learning in both ways
so
the scholars here can also learn from
people especially people
how they have been
managing resources their traditional
knowledge
their knowledge that help
to keep the biodiversity sofa intact and
these are very important thing
biodiversity in himalayan vision is
useful uh to the whole world
so
it's very beneficial for both i think
um the himalayan problems are such that
they require
an interdisciplinary perspective to
understand them and
to to find out any solution
so single disciplinary approach cannot
cannot be enough for that my concern has
been that uh we have we never could
achieve research which uh considers both
biophysical cultural and social aspects
so it it's it has been a very
challenging area i have not seen any
paper which really represents both in a
balanced way so i thought that uh
this approach of uh the the courage
ali nustri and the and its collaborators
are showing
uh have shown that uh they can really
take up this kind of study i think it's
it's remarkable